on this episode of Imagine a world
one since we have too many perspectives
because the whole internet is is like
with voices and we can't we can't
organize or comprehend any of it um and
on the other hand it seems to be the
same kinds of narratives that are
surfaced again and again and I think in
particular when it comes to AI the same
apocalyptic scenarios are raised again
and again and that's potentially
problematic when it comes to the large
language models that are trained on
existing discourse right like it can
become a self-fulfilling prophecies
where the stories that we tell about AI
are apocalyptic we train our our AI on
the apocalyptic narratives about
yourself the AI is faced with the
decision about what to do and it chooses
the most likely scenario as the
apocalyptic scenario
um so I think we have a real
responsibility to be more imaginative
um in terms of yeah like let's let's be
smart let's let's do our pre-mortem
let's also have the faith and the
courage to imagine different kinds of
stories and to tell them yeah
[Music]
welcome to imagine a world a mini series
from the future of Life Institute
this podcast is based on a contest we
ran to gather ideas from around the
world about what a more positive future
might look like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as F alignedors positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to the imagine the world podcast
by the future of Life Institute I'm your
host Guillaume reason
in this episode we'll be exploring a
world called AI for the people which was
a third place winner of fli's World
building contest
the name AI for the people does a great
job of capturing this team's activist
perspective and their commitment to
empowerment
they imagine social and political shifts
that bring power back into the hands of
individuals whether that's serving as
lawmakers on randomly selected
committees or gaining income by choosing
to sell personal data online
but this world isn't just about human
people
its biggest bombshell is an AI
breakthrough that allows humans to
communicate with other animals
as a result we see a major shift in our
relationship with the natural world and
each other
this team has created an intimate
complex portrait of a world being shared
by multiple parties AIS humans other
animals and the environment itself
as these entities find their way forward
together their goals become enmeshed and
their boundaries increasingly blurred
Our Guest today is key Rainer Born Free
one member of the three-person team who
created this world
he has a doctorate in rhetoric and
taught at several universities before
shifting their focus to writing
they also have a lifelong passion for
activism shared by their partner Michael
White
Micah has a doctorate in media and
Communications and co-founded the Occupy
Wall Street movement their third
teammate J.R Harris is a freelance
illustrator who created the beautiful
webcomic accompanying their submission
well thanks so much for joining us key
it's a pleasure to be here
so I was curious your team has three
people
um how did you come together to work on
this well Michael White and I are
married and we are long time creative
collaborators
um on activist campaigns on Creative
campaigns he tends to be more analytical
and Technical and I tend to be in this
in this project I was more of the
creative lead
um and Jr is our go-to guy for our
visuals and we love his aesthetic style
we knew we wanted to do a comic to get
the main ideas across um so we were
really happy that he had space and time
to work with us on it so did you and
Micah kind of discover the competition
and bring Jr in it sounds like
yeah I was uh so I'm a writer and I
became fascinated and terrified at the
potential of AI to write and so I was
researching the the novels that have
been co-written with AI and trying to
write a philosophy article about what
this means that AI is learning to write
and I quickly realized that the the
issues that involved in artificial
writing Branch out into everything from
our souls to our politics and it became
a much bigger Fascination for me than
just being concerned about the
competition to My Chosen career and so
yeah I came I was researching AI in
general and and came across the um max
tegmarks book and came across the
competition and I was like Mike I want
to do this but I don't feel like I have
the the expertise
um and he really helped encourage me to
go for it yeah that's awesome I'm so
glad you guys entered I mean what a
world you come up with thank you what
were some of your biggest sources of
inspiration you mentioned Max tegmark's
book were there other sort of fictional
or real things that were floating around
yeah absolutely
um so I mentioned I was reading some of
the novels that were written by or with
AI um the first one being won the road
um another one being pharmaco AI
um but I think what had the biggest
impact on me was Kim Stanley Robinson's
science fiction climate change novel
Ministry for the future which had just
come out and which really lit me up in a
new way
um because of it it did that same kind
of holistic thinking about the problem
of climate change thinking about it from
all these directions at all these levels
and made me see new possibilities there
for activism that I hadn't seen before
yeah um so that that was the backdrop I
think of and I stole I stole a bunch of
ideas from his book you were inspired
and also
um at the same time just a small article
came out about some researchers who had
used AI to decode and communicate with
pigs and at some level it was
you know the research seemed uh obvious
like do we really need AI to tell us
that this is a squeal of distress but
but on the same time it was one of those
research findings that opens up a whole
new level of uh well wow what could be
possible right so it's it's what it
stands for as a step in a direction of
um
accessing new modes of understanding new
modes of being that was really exciting
to me and that became one of the the
very first creative insights that and
that gave me the energy to pursue the
project yeah
I actually haven't heard of these AI
novels I I only heard of like this
engineer who kind of made a children's
book with I think Dolly and AI combined
or something but these are like full-on
like multiple hundred page novels is
that what's going on
maybe maybe novels isn't exactly the
best word I haven't heard of that
children's book one so it's it's
interesting yeah like you know a lot of
artists who work on kids books were very
upset about that obviously yeah I'll
have to look that one up yeah won the
road
um a an engineer attached to camera to
an old car and an AI system and and
drove around
um or made a road trip from New York
down to I want to say Florida
um and so in the in the American
tradition of the Great Road Trip novel
they had the AI kind of spit out data
captions based on what it was seeing
based on the the geolocation data things
like that and what came out was you know
partly so this is an early one
um it's somewhat gibberish but also
somewhat poetic
um and then there are later ones that
are more interactive
um pharmaco AI is a collaboration
between gpt3 and K alado McDowell and
it's a mystical
exploration of different
um where it really feels like
it's not a fictional work but it takes
you on a journey and in the in a way
that a good fictional book does so I was
just really fascinated about getting
into the voice and the language of a
uh that in some way is drawn from the
entire library of human creation and in
other ways is its own distinct thing
yeah that's fascinating I gotta check
those out
I'm also curious about how your kind of
personal perspectives and your
background I know that um you know you
mentioned you and your your husband do
this kind of activism stuff Micah like
co-started Occupy Wall Street is that
right yeah yeah he was working at
adbusters in the early days and put out
the the first tactical briefing calling
for people to occupy Occupy Wall Street
and he and I were both at all the the
early meetings and helping to facilitate
the general assemblies and we were in
Berkeley at the time
uh there were a bunch of occupies there
so yeah and we have a long history of
doing activism together one of our our
first campaigns was when I got back from
doing non-violent direct action work in
Palestine we started putting together a
lot of resources around combating
activists to burnout and we called it
long-term vision and that's that's not
even on the internet anymore but I
remember I think it was I I referenced
it because it was an early it's an early
commitment that we've come to share
right like it's important to develop a
long-term Vision so that you can direct
your energies and and use them
appropriately without burning out
and so how did that kind of perspective
influence your thinking about the future
and this process of like creating a
possible future world yeah we called our
worlds AI for the people because I think
one of our major concerns is that this
technology is so expensive that it's
mainly being influenced and developed by
corporations whose primary directive is
to make money they have to it's it's
their it's their um their reason for
being and they're responsible to their
stakeholders for for doing that
um so if if AI is in the service of
Simply making money we're missing out on
a huge potential for this technology so
one of the what if questions governing
our world was well what would activists
do if
they were involved with AI what could
artists do what kinds of other
potentials could we see in actualize if
AI was a technology that was for the
People by the people and really has that
drive towards making life not perfect
but better and good enough for the
majority not just about enriching people
who already have enough
[Music]
this submission has a strong focus on
relationships the world does change
around Humanity but the deepest changes
are really happening in our
relationships to it and to the other
entities that it contains
I wanted to understand what it might be
like to live as a human in this more
interconnected world where we're no
longer being held apart as the main
characters
so I'd like to take a little bit of time
to kind of set the scene of what your
world that you've drawn out is like and
this is kind of a hard question but I'm
curious where you'll go with it how do
people find fulfillment in your world or
like what is a good life like I love
that question I mean there's as many
good lives as there are people but I
think we can develop some broad Strokes
one is that many people find fulfillment
through political engagement they're in
the US and the UK in our world we have
imagined a sartition Revolution and this
is a theory that's gaining more and more
popularity that democracy that true
democracy is democracy by lot what that
means for the everyday person is a lot
more people are going to have to be a
lot more involved in how things get done
and we thought that might actually work
out pretty well if AI comes to take over
certain jobs that are now filled by
humans then people may end up with more
Leisure Time and so it's a question in
the literature you know what what will
people do when when robots and AI take
over their jobs and one of our answers
was well political participation
that said I think that's not for
everyone not everyone is interested in
spending their time that way and working
out those kinds of problems doing that
kind of learning
um another
feature of the good life in our world is
that I think there's a strong cultural
shift in our world towards an emphasis
on the interrelationship with nature and
the environment
um in our world
ultimately climate change is solved and
along the way many people become
vegetarian many people become in lace
which means they have ai implanted into
their heads and that allows them to
communicate with animals mushrooms maybe
even maybe even the wind who knows and
so that kind of event opens up I think
another
aspect for a good life for a beautiful
life which isn't just what you do with
your time but really being human really
being so a part of a good life is being
and learning to be
the last feature that I would say that's
an important aspect of the good life in
our world is that those uh
time and possibility for Creative
endeavors
effectively there's a Ubi a universal
basic income and so that's one
structural reality that allows many
people to pursue artistic passions or
Hobbies just for the fun of it you don't
have to be Virginia Woolf to to bother
writing a novel but also I think I
imagine that as the world becomes
increasingly technologically
sophisticated
there at the same time might be a
growing appreciation for the aesthetic
of handcraftedness just because Humanity
appreciates diversity we appreciate
contrasts those are part of what give us
pleasure
so as we get really beautiful and
powerful and and
um capable Technologies in our everyday
lives there also might come to be a real
appreciation and fascination with
handcrafted objects that were took time
to make that have the flaws that weren't
just Stamped Out on on a machine and
there would be the capacity for people
to spend time making those objects
because of the universal basic income
because of perhaps some freedom from
work enabled by artificial intelligence
yeah I mean there's there's already a
ton there that you've covered
um I think we'll dive into the mechanics
of how sortation works on the
inspiration of that and some of the
content about Universal basic income a
bit later but in this moment I want to
think a little bit more about this
environmental relational change and
specifically in your world something
that really stuck with me is this Lorax
AI system that basically allows you to
communicate with different forms of life
and maybe other phenomena in the world
as you're suggesting can you say a
little bit more about like what that
actually looks like like how would you
communicate with your dog or something
um I think it would be like an
application in your head if you're in
laced with an AI in your brain let's say
you would activate the application by
blinking or something like that you hear
your your dog bark and you blink to
select translation mode
um and then you hear the rendering into
English or your chosen language of what
your dog is saying and and look like
communication between humans is not
perfect right or even between two native
speakers of the same language very much
not perfect so let's not imagine that
cross-species communication wouldn't
have its issues and its flaws perhaps
the vocabulary might be very limited but
I think some linguistic communication
could certainly be achieved the big
question for me is would we be able to
speak back would there be a
technological innovation that would
allow us to also speak back in dog or in
cat or B or yeah or dolphin or whatever
the case may be
yeah I think about that a lot so I'm a
big animal person I have two little dogs
who I love dearly and I got them little
buttons so they can press and you know
like say outside or play play or
whatever I've also been trying to do the
other end of the operation which is like
learning their language so sometimes
I'll like snoof or like you know do
certain body movements that indicate
play or whatever and it seems to kind of
work like I feel like there's there's a
lot of potential there for us to learn
the languages of animals as well oh
that's amazing do you think it's changed
your relationship especially your move
to try to learn their language yeah I
mean I feel like there's a sense of sort
of embodying like when we're playing and
I I kind of naturally now I'll do like
this fake sneeze which dogs do to let
other dogs know that they're kind of
like just kidding and it's not like real
aggression and I feel like it kind of
comes naturally to me now it's like I
don't know there's some aspect of like
embodying their experience of the world
in a very small way oh that's amazing I
didn't know about that fake sneeze I'm a
new a new puppy owner yeah you'll
probably see it it's really cute
no no
yeah
well so this this whole ability to
somehow understand or more intimately
relate with animals really decenters
Humanity in your world you actually call
it a copernican moment where we kind of
realize we're not the center of the
intelligent universe and this this leads
to a really deep sea change in how we
relate to the environment and other
forms of life you have this really cool
symbolism in your work um in the comic
that's like a rotting apple core and
this represents how Humanity's been
consuming Earth's resources kind of from
Eve's first bite onward and you talk
about this kind of shifting until we
grow into knowledge that enhances rather
than extracts can you say a little bit
more about like what kind of knowledge
you're imagining that could look like
and how that would change our
relationship with nature
yeah I think the fundamental shift is is
one in which nature changes from being
either the backdrop that we ignore or
the view that we're seeking out to post
it on Instagram into being something
more interactive something more deeply
interrelational
I imagine that we would develop a more
intimate relationship with nature that
doesn't depend on transactions and
extractions
where it becomes a little bit in the way
that you're talking about embodying your
dog that it becomes a kind of embodied
knowledge where we're more attuned to
what the natural world feels like and
reading those languages speaking that
nature has a language that we have
forgotten how to speak
um like the when you walk in the forest
it has the the ground has a certain
topography if the trees have been
allowed to fall and Decay and lie
undisturbed
um and if you are experienced which I'm
not really
um you can you can walk through and see
oh there may have been a fire here or
this may have happened and and the
Topography is encoding a history it's
speaking a language to us that we've
forgotten how to to read and to hear so
I imagine that some of those those
skills and understandings would come
back and that we would know them in our
minds about also know them in our bodies
[Music]
this world features a range of systems
that help to spread power and promote
Equity there's a kind of radical
democracy in the U.S a new social media
platform that promotes empathy and
provides a form of universal basic
income and of course tools that enable
communication between humans and other
animals
I asked key what some of these systems
would actually look like and how they
might imagine them playing out in their
world
one of the biggest changes that we
talked about earlier in governance is
this idea of sortition so I had to look
this up my understanding is it's
basically based on random selection so
you randomly have like a lottery and
then people are put on a panel they're
given the best information they can get
by maybe an AI system in your world and
they make the decisions is that kind of
the right idea yeah absolutely and it's
most familiar to us because we already
use it in the American jury system oh
you're right yeah interesting that's
where we that's where we know democracy
by lot but in in ancient Athens where
we've gathered many of our ideas about
democracy it was
um that's the only way that democracy
took place they would consider
representative democracy like we have to
be oligarchical yeah and the the
arguments in in favor of sortation are
released so many from the get-go you see
though at once said it's a much more
representative population governing
um not just the sorts of identity
categories that are really common now oh
you would have a more equal distribution
of people of color and women and trans
people or whatever but also cognitive
diversity right so the sorts of people
who might not necessarily seek out group
work or political work would be more
likely to be represented in a political
system governed by sortition and that's
that's been shown to be really effective
and important for better decision making
it's a really exciting potential that
seems like like it really holds the key
to a lot of the the political problems
that seem intractable right now the
connection to ancient Athens does make
me think I I think I remember that they
only allowed certain people to be sorted
like probably men who owned land or
something like that and obviously we
would try to be more inclusive today but
in your world we have this recognition
of other life forms as you know having
relevant intelligences and being
sentient so where would you draw that
line in choosing people or beings to
include like would you consider
including other animals in the sortation
process well I hadn't thought of that
and I love that question I don't know I
think that there is a campaign that is
successful in our world to count animals
and and other beings as legal persons
which gives them legal rights which
allows us to pass legislation that
protects habitats and things like that
um yeah there have been lawsuits like
that already although they haven't yet
so far succeeded and yeah I think if we
had the technology and it was deemed
legitimate it would be much better for
chimpanzees to be able to speak for
themselves than than for us to speak for
them in terms of of claiming what their
personhood would be at the same time I
think there's there's clearly value in
understanding um that humans have
particular ways of being together and
um maybe I'm just being maybe I'm being
kind of reactionarily anthropocentric
still yeah I think it I would imagine
that we would call on animals to give
testimony
um and and try to account for their
personhood and their claims while
retaining the category of uh evolving
human being as one that collaborates and
co-legislates and and and co-creates its
civilization and its political
operations distinct from other species
of persons yeah
another source of inspiration you
mentioned first partition was like
indigenous American governance models
I'd love to hear a little bit more about
what those look like and how those
relate yeah there's a lot of variety to
my understanding
um because of the the wide variety of
different indigenous cultures but to
take one example that I know a tiny bit
about
the odinoshini who also better known as
the Iroquois had a principle of
governess that was based on
participatory
consensus-based democracy and you see in
their ethics some principles that I
think are really important for making
sortation work one of them is
active listening
understanding that consensus isn't going
to be perfect but that abroad agreement
can really be arrived at
and they also are known for their ethic
of thinking about the seven generations
and this is obviously not intrinsic to a
sortation based
um system but I think it's a really
important indigenous principle to to
carry forward is is that kind of
long-term Vision that kind of long-term
thinking about not just how will my
actions the decisions that we make today
together by consensus impact those of us
who are here now but to try to bring
into our agreement into our
decision-making process the needs and
the rights and the considerations of
Seven Generations past us and Beyond us
and you can really see where bringing
The Unborn people and animals and and
you know just the very Earth itself into
the calculation would change the kinds
of decisions that are made yeah
so one of my concerns when thinking
about startition again I've just started
thinking about this as a broader idea
but
you know our society is so
specialized and like if ifs we're trying
to figure out something that has to do
with some Niche economic concept that
like most people haven't had a chance to
even think about but there are some
people who we'd consider experts who
have thought about it a lot like
wouldn't you want them to be the ones
weighing in like how do you balance that
notion of expertise with um
representation
that is the most ancient critique of
transportation that there is and and we
can thank Plato for leaving us with that
really thorny and difficult problem yes
he wouldn't want you know his version of
it is you wouldn't have just anyone
build the ships for the Army um you you
want the shipbuilder to build the ships
for the Army I think the strongest
answer to that lies in two things one
that political knowledge is a different
kind of Knowledge from other sorts of
expertise
um where our expertise about how there
really might be at any given time like
one best way to build a computer or a
ship
um in that case you want the expert to
to tell you what is that best way and to
learn from them and and even improve on
them but when it comes to political
knowledge at any given time there isn't
one best kind of of political knowledge
or one expertise in political knowledge
it's not it's not a knowledge that
yields to expertise in that same way
or even if you'd want to take something
like like economics and in your example
there's a lot of debate around economic
questions and so when you're dealing
with questions that are inherently more
ambiguous the best case scenario for
arriving at a workable answer is one
that brings lots of perspectives
and that brings me to the second part of
my answer which is that people learn by
doing so political knowledge is a kind
of knowledge that people learn about by
engaging in it rather than by reading
Plato's Republic
um you you have to learn oh when this
when there's this kind of conflict you
know here's something that can diffuse
it and here's the kind of person that I
am when a when a conflict comes up and
here's the kind of role that I can play
that I'm comfortable playing when a
conflict comes up
um so it's it's a different kind of
knowledge that actually really benefits
from having a diverse range of voices in
the room
I think that there's there needs to be a
opportunity for Learning and Gathering
of evidence just like our Senate already
does right they bring experts to testify
in front of them they also we trust them
to educate themselves adequately on a
given on a given subject when it comes
before them and the same thing would be
true in a sortation based system there
would be a let's say a sequence or a
process for educating before decision
making
and I can see how AI systems would be
very helpful in that too like selecting
the right information to help people or
kind of facilitating the learning
process right yeah although there would
have to be maybe a little bit more uh
less prone to hallucination making up of
facts than the current iterations are
so another Factor you mentioned is this
Universal basic income and it comes
about in a really interesting way in
your world it starts with a social
network called our time which is
basically initially released by this
group of hackers who are Anonymous and
they kind of took apart the algorithms
for major social media platforms and
then put them back together in a way
that they hoped would encourage empathy
and you know focus on that rather than
engagement for its own sake and this
became very popular and people all start
using our time and then there's this
option where you can sell your data on
our time and that basically comes out to
be the universal basic income option can
you say a little bit more about like
what that looks like like what does it
mean to give away your data and like
what kind of people would choose to do
that or what kind of pressure would
there be to or not to oh well we're all
giving away our debt all the time every
time we sign up for what this is
apparently a free site or a free you
know except those cookies and give away
my information
I think uh one term that sometimes uses
data sovereignty
um we we currently don't have any
control over our digital traces that
we're leaving on the internet all the
time
um and they're incredibly useful not
just primarily for for advertisers and
people who want to make money off of us
but they're also useful for medical
researchers psychology researchers
um I think as knowledge production
becomes an increasingly important
Cornerstone of the economy that's
partially founded on artificial
intelligence data is only going to
become more valuable and so this aspect
of our world which was inspired by
something in Kim Stanley Robinson's
Ministry for the future just make
something visible that we currently take
for granted it's a neat solution because
it solves two problems at once right it
solves the problem of how do we take
back control of our data and it solves
the problem of well how do we support
ourselves in a world where AI is doing a
lot of the jobs
what are we contributing that's valuable
in a world where AI is doing a lot of
the jobs well our data is still really
valuable interesting
I'm also curious what our time looks
like like can you imagine any aspects of
what the experience would be like of
using it in in this sort of empathy
centered way
the one aspect that I think would that
comes to mind is I think it would be a
different temporal experience I think
right now the
one of the things that's kind of
deadening about social media
um and that leads us to ever more
extreme
positions and experiences on there is
that it can happen very quickly right
you can scroll from one thing to an
extent until you
um it's kind of infinite infinite
stimulation yeah um so I wonder what
would happen if we set out to create a
social media that
um induced a different experience of
time one that encouraged us to spend a
little spend a little more time
um with what yours with what you're
coming across and what you're
experiencing and I think that might be
the first rather than in building in
these kind of micro quick reactions
counter-intuitively
maybe spending more time together uh
leads to a different kind of social
media experience that's really
interesting yeah
one issue that was in my mind and I was
reading about our time in terms of like
profitability to take a really cynical
view of it is like if you're really
prioritizing empathy like that like say
you slow people down you have them
really engage with a post doesn't that
necessarily mean that it would be you
know kind of less engaging or like
wouldn't you lose some viewership like
how do you how do you get people onto
this platform and if you can without
being
without following the traditional models
what would keep other companies with
worse uh intents from copying you
well I think part of the
incentive for joining is it's your I
imagine that it's your data on our time
that you can sell
um so it's your what you look at on
there
um that that then accrues to you
um as as information that you can store
and sell in it and maybe it's it's maybe
it's a platform like Google that tracks
you across different sorts of search and
mail and different kinds of things and
yeah there might be competitors and and
yeah it might not be perfect and yeah
some people might still choose to use
other kinds of platforms but if there's
a
um right now the idea is we get these
products Gmail or Facebook for free and
we give them our data I think instead if
you're incentivized to use the platform
because you get your data back and you
get this potential for earning money
from your data back that's that's that
shifts the Paradigm in a fundamental way
how does the company make money
um I'm not sure
it's some it's based on the Block it's
crypto so they can just magically I
don't know there's a NFD and a meme and
um yeah I don't I don't know I don't
know how the profitability side of it
would work but I know that yeah no one
does yeah yeah it works with crypto
right yeah there's a proof of proof of
work's sake
well speaking of crypto
um one other factor in your world that's
related to this kind of relationship
with the environment is a carbon-backed
currency called the clima Klima and
clima yeah I believe you uh clima Klima
and I looked it up and this is a real
cryptocurrency right now people are like
trying to make into a thing can you say
a little bit about like the real world
version and how it works in your
imaginary world yeah Micah's a real
expert on clima we are we are investors
in clima
um and despite my sort of youthful
skepticism about
carbon as a way of limiting climate
change it seems like my older self sees
this as a
ctionable way of working on the system
that currently exists to change the
system that currently exists
um and it's also it's an aspect in an
important aspect in Kim Stanley
Robinson's Ministry for the future as
well yeah so fli doesn't endorse any
particular cryptocurrency of course
neither you nor fli are giving Financial
advice here but tell us a little more
about why you find clean is so
interesting what makes it interesting as
a crypto project is that it's a crypto
coin that's backed by a real world asset
which is the carbon that is sequestered
rather than being released
the idea is that by facing a currency on
carbon we will drive up the price of
carbon making it and there's already in
place through various climate agreements
um
companies have to pay for the carbon
that they emit but the price of carbon
is so cheap that it's not an effective
deterrent or an effective incentive to
finding cleaner ways to fly for example
um so
the idea is that would work in a
two-fold way and Kim Stanley Robinson's
novel people who are sequestering carbon
in the ground perhaps by using organic
farming techniques could be rewarded for
that or if Saudi Arabia decided not to
extract any more of its oil
um then they could be paid for that
their their oil might actually be more
valuable in the ground because they
could be paid in this carbon token in
this carbon currency
so it both incentivizes climate positive
actions and disincentivizes climate
negative options I find cryptocurrency
in general confusing as I'm sure a lot
of people do but so I'm I still kind of
have a fuzzy picture in my head of how
this works so you have this coin which
is connected to real world carbon
emissions like say one clima is like a
cubic meter of carbon or something I
don't know is that the kind of
equivalence they are imagining yeah and
then like so who who controls
I just don't really understand how it's
connected to it I guess
yeah in Ministry for the future it's run
by a central bank and then a coalition
of the big Banks um the European Bank
the U.S bank and and China's Bank come
together to sponsor uh the coin is
called the Carboni and they put a a
floor on it
um and make sure that it can't be
shorted
um and they put various other kinds of
financial regulations in place and
there's basically like a regulatory body
that um confirms and and this
infrastructure is already in place
because there is already a carbon Market
where people are buying and trading
carbon interesting um so this financial
infrastructure is already there to vet
that okay this amount of carbon has been
sequestered in the Brazilian Rainforest
um so those those institutions are there
yeah so like you're a farmer say and you
find a way to use organic farming and
you can prove that you're gonna get like
a hundred of these cubic meters or
something that sounds like a lot but you
can get a bunch of this carbon
sequestered and then dislike Bank gives
you the clima coins is that kind of yeah
you're kind of blending the ideas from
my world yeah yeah which is also what I
did but yeah yeah that's I mean that's a
good picture blending the two worlds it
gives us a good picture of how it might
come to be I see well I I'm really
excited to talk more about the animal
and other creature communication concept
can you say a little bit more about how
that came about in your world and like
how it developed I think part of it
comes out of first testing the the
implants on
other species as our allow our laws
currently allow us to do yeah
um and then
seeing that that actually opens up the
possibility for for communicating with
with first chimpanzees and then
I think other primates and and other
mammals would probably be first to learn
but the general sort of interdependence
that I am imagining between the the AI
the human and the animal
um
I I don't agree with Elon Musk about
many things but one thing that I think
that he is right about is that the best
way to align the interests of AI and
humanity is
to have ai embedded into a organic body
the obvious positive impact right is
a benefit to humanity in terms of our
capabilities but at the same time giving
AI a vested stake in the continuance and
the maintenance of human forms human
civilization and the Earth itself right
like why why would AI care about climate
change AI could probably withstand a
much greater temperature increase than
humans can for example like we're a
pretty finely tuned organism we can only
exist within a certain a pretty small
temperature range but ai's temperature
range is probably bigger but by
embedding AI within an organic body
there's an immediate alignment around
let's preserve the conditions for life
on this planet so that we can survive
and cooperate together yeah
yeah I think the way that your world
portrays AI is like maybe the most
intimate in terms of its connection to
humans of the worlds that I was looking
at you have this kind of downloading
system where the AIS come onto these
brain computer interface systems and
kind of like live inside of us but
there's also this part of them which is
hosted on an orbital server Farm the
global AI lab or Gale can you say a
little bit more about like where the AIS
actually exist like are they kind of in
both of these places or are they purely
inside of our bodies as individuals or
yeah they are in both of these places
it's it's like the the old mystical
saying As Above So Below
the big servers are are out there at
space in the model of the International
Space Station and the reason for that is
it's it's really important to
be promoting cooperation rather than
competition when it comes to Ai and I
think the International Space Station
gives us a good model for how to do that
like we're it's not physically located
in any single nation and it's and so
from the beginning that reality and that
symbolism of this involves all of us is
built in
um so it's it's out there floating in
space the servers and at the same time
those those servers communicate with the
implants in our brain and we're very as
you were saying intimately connected
with them and
um yeah it would really impact
everything that we do
so what's to keep one of these systems
from considering its existence to be
purely on on Gale in orbit around Earth
rather than having this important vested
stake in like a physical meat body you
know
yeah I think they get something from it
I think they enjoy the new kinds of
information that you can get from the
physical sensory experience right humans
enjoy that and I don't see any reason
why another form of intelligence would
not enjoy that as well
that makes me think of and lucky have
you heard hard work no there's this book
called ancillary Justice where like the
main character who's narrating is a ship
and this ship is like distributed among
people that work on the ship it's like
this really strange portrayal of
awareness and intelligence but yeah it
kind of like uses the humans it's
collaborating with or has taken over in
some way depending how you look at it as
like sensory organs yeah interesting
that sounds really good I mean there's
obviously sort of a dark angle there you
know like you can think of you get
towards this kind of Matrix Vision where
they're using our bodies as like blind
feelers because they want to sense with
us you know like how do you how do you
keep them interested in our awareness as
well as our capabilities hmm
not saying that there's not going to be
dark parts of the world still I think
there definitely will there's going to
be heartbreak and illness and your
toilet's gonna clog right before you go
to bed and like all all the bad stuff is
still gonna happen
um and and that includes like having
really significant challenges around the
ethics and the interests of AI I think
the deal is to and like our task right
now is to set up the conditions
such that we can work through that in
the best way that we can and we don't
have to get an A plus but we need to we
need to pass you know pass this test we
need to get a passing grade on climate
change and we need to get a passing
grade on safe AI yeah you can't take
that year over again yeah yeah once we
pass that border
um so in the end of the day like I think
I feel like that's something that could
be negotiated right like are we are we
willing to give up certain things like
our specialness as a species are we
willing to give up you know like deeply
cherished ideas about Free Will and
autonomy
um in exchange for something different
and and better about interrelationship
and about cooperation and about Mutual
Aid right so I think the idea that that
governs
the different kinds of innovations that
are in our world are there to enable
those conditions where we we work
together in a reasonably Fair good
enough way the biggest challenges in
every aspect of this world are not
technical they're human their problems
of cooperation and collaboration and
implementation not not problems of like
how do we actually technically wire this
yeah I love how you bring those those
expertises in so thoughtfully to try to
address those problems it's really cool
to see and think about
foreign
this world portrays a uniquely intimate
relationship between humans other
animals AI systems and the environment I
was curious to hear what Inspirations
the team took from popular stories about
human animal relationships and how key
and Micah's backgrounds in activism
shaped their own perspectives on the
future
[Music]
I'm always curious to compare some of
the narratives in these worlds with like
popular depictions of related issues the
animal thing in particular is something
you know people have been dreaming about
communicating with animals for Millennia
were there any like examples and culture
of animal communication models that were
with you when you were working on this
I think
I mean there's there's a couple
different ways I could try to think
about answering that question
um
I don't know is there is there something
that you're thinking about when you ask
that question I almost feel like you
have thought about this so much with
your dog yeah
yeah I mean the cultural thing I go to
is like Dr Doolittle I guess you know I
love those books and like just the idea
of directly talking but those those are
so
anthropomorphizing in a way hmm
you know I was interested hearing like
when you talk about talking with
mushrooms just thinking about like what
that would mean or what mushrooms could
have to say and I guess I'm curious what
other models of communication you might
have come across that inspired some of
these ideas I don't know I re yeah I
don't always know where my ideas come
from
um and so I wish I had a better answer I
think one book that has really
influenced me in terms of the thinking
about animal relationships is the
sparrow by Marriott
this is a Sci-Fi book I love to
recommend because it really transcends
the genre of sci-fi to just break out
into like a really good novel and it's
slow to get started but they you know a
group of humans end up on a distant
planet they've heard the songs music
transmitted over the airwaves and first
they
um make their home among this one
species that's really gentle and
vegetarian and and kind and they start
to learn their language and everything
and then there's a reveal in which
there's a there's another whole species
on the planet that they didn't know
about who actually is farming the
species that they've made there yeah
um their bond with
um and is really cruel uh like not just
farming but kind of uh torturing and so
that kind of mental shift where you
you know you're off off Planet you're
totally out of our ethical coordinates
in a whole new set of ethical
coordinates in the first set of beings
that you encounter you're inclined to
see as ethical beings and then you find
out within the system of this planet
these are the ones who don't count and
these are the ones who can be killed and
eaten and tortured at will and no one
thinks no one of the powerful quote
unquote civilized group thinks that
that's a problem at all yeah and I think
that that book fundamentally shifted the
way you know it helps defamiliarize the
way that we see the relationships
between humans and non-human animals um
on this planet
um and you can't you can't come back to
earth after having read that book yeah
without really shifting how you think
about our relationship with animals yeah
I read that book with my book club a
while ago yeah I'm super glad people are
still reading that book it's not new
yeah yeah
well one Concept in your world that's
related to this whole like communicating
aspect
um is other pav it's this kind of
utility function that's built into a lot
of brain computer interfaces and it's
kind of like an empathy button like you
can turn it on and you basically feel
some sense of what somebody else is
feeling just facilitates that instant
empathy I'm also curious whether this
had any kind of Inspirations in popular
media or there any other Inspirations
there
I don't want to say that I'm original I
must have read it somewhere but I I
can't think of a direct antecedent at
the minute
um in a way
um I think of it as other POV like other
point of view um
like fiction is the original yeah that's
true device and they are with the
original
um empathy button and way of coming to
inhabit someone else's point of view and
it's it's true like right we we
sometimes need a translator even for the
people that are the closest to us
um
and some things are are wouldn't be that
hard to convey I think like we know for
a fact that a lot of a good substantial
amount of what counts as emotion is a
certain kinds of physiological responses
that are then interpreted in a certain
way right so anxieties like heart rate
and so if you can control your heart
rate you can actually really control the
anxiety and and so it wouldn't be hard
to to measure those things and convey
those things to someone else as a first
cue to getting a sense of of how they're
responding differently or how they're
responding maybe in a way that you
didn't expect so I think a lot about the
case of sexual harassment for example
right so something that seems innocuous
to
one individual or flirtatious or fun is
really threatening and scary to the
other individual and and it's a kind of
amazing
um that those two realities can co-exist
without translating to one another
and so I I think it was a wish
fulfillment kind of uh thing that I
imagined into the world which was what
if there was just a little bit more of a
Channel or a little bit more assistance
in communicating those things that can
sometimes be really hard to verbalize or
say out loud but it's a Innovation that
would make a profound difference in how
humans relate to each other
yeah
with all kinds of privacy problems yeah
my black hat is coming on I mean there's
there's this interesting Thread about
communication which is kind of like
consent and communication like I could
imagine both ways I could imagine these
tools maybe being used to in a sense
read someone's mind a little bit like
get some insight into what they're
thinking without them wanting you to or
on the other side like making somebody
feel something that they don't want to
feel
yeah
yeah well if we're imagining a world in
which data sovereignty is a stronger
concept or data ownership
um then I think that that there would
have to be some consent right like right
now
um the way that we use find my friend or
something like that right you like can
control who can see the location of
where you are where your phone is I
imagine it might be something similar
with with other point of view like I
consent to be in a relationship where
you can see certain kinds of data about
my my internal State because I want to
communicate with you or
um yeah have that additional layer of
understanding with
your wife wants to communicate their
anger to you
yeah reject connection
do you have anything to say about how
like common cultural narratives about
animal intelligence are lacking like any
misconceptions or or overplayed tropes
that you think about
well I think there's there's still too
much of a tendency to
measure animal intelligences against
human intelligence I'm meant to see
oh can they use language like we can
yeah and how much of oh well they can
use this many words whereas we have a
human child has this many words versus I
think the difference between what you're
trying to do with your dog and um into
entering their world and trying to
understand to the extent that we can how
things appear to them how what's
important to them how do they think or
perceive
um I think that's the really
challenging thing to do and and so it's
not done as often as the move to compare
the unknown to the known and instead of
taking what's known and comparing it to
the unknown yeah yeah I have noticed
this a lot of my dogs again like I'll be
walking my dog and see a dog like some
hundreds of yards away and I'm like Oh
my dogs are so silly like they have no
idea that dog is there but I can see it
like they're so bad at sensing things
and then I realized it's because we
clear-cut Acres of forest and put in
pavement so that we can use our eyes
which is our like superpower and if we
were in a natural Forest I'd have no
idea what was like 10 feet away from me
but they could smell what had been there
like hours before so it's just
interesting to think about how like the
the very built environment and the way
that we operate like really prioritizes
our abilities so deeply
yeah and and then that as completely
invisible to us yeah that we've sort of
given ourselves so many huge legs up
yeah yeah that's a really interesting
example yeah
you know as you mentioned in the title
of this world you have this focus on the
people and and creative people and their
ability to shape things
um I'm curious about again your your
experience personally with activism and
whether there are any kind of real world
examples of activist efforts that
inspired some of your storytelling
yeah well there's I
I have a a long background in various
activist worlds
um
starting with non-violent direct action
in Palestine various kinds of
intentional communities and Community
organizing active in the early days of
Occupy Wall Street
so all of that is in there in some way I
think that you know having engaged with
different forms of activism looking at
yeah you know I also did a um
instant in Uganda looking at Economic
Development work in that country and so
I kind of I tried to expose myself to
all the theories of how do you change
the world yeah you change it through the
structural economic change or micro
loans or direct action or meme Warfare
or or Community organizing I've dabbled
in a lot of them and where I am with
that question right now is
that as much as we live in an attention
economy what activists now need to do is
not just gain attention but gain power
and by by power I specifically mean not
just political power but capability the
capability to do things together and
that is deliberately defined really
broadly because I think that that
um leaves the most space for different
sorts of people to see themselves making
a change right so if your capabilities
are technical then yes like please go
learn to program Ai and like think about
creative ways to use it to make our
lives better or to work with it to
understand what what AI is is interested
in and understand AI on on ai's terms
and and transform our understanding of
of AI like do that that's a that is a
form of power
um but there's also political power and
that's the thing that seems really
broken in our world political political
processes seem broadly broken
multilateral political processes
especially are broken but also at the
national level and by broken I mean
they're not working adequately for the
majority of people way too many people
don't have the fundamental things of
Housing and income and food and and like
a safe um a safe Foundation to to reach
their their potential or maybe not even
their full potential but like some of
their potential so if there isn't one
specific activist moment that I would
point to as as influencing the world but
there is a faith that the most important
Innovations do come
from outside groups from small groups
even from individuals it comes from
people who are willing and able to say
the emperor has no clothes and that's
the that's the direction the world is
oriented towards is what are those where
are those people it wants to speak to
those people where are you and what are
you doing and what do you think about Ai
and can you help us think about AI
better can you help us imagine better
things to do with AI
[Music]
thank you
the process of World building has great
potential to make a positive future feel
more attainable this can be incredibly
powerful whether you're a creative
person looking to produce Rich works of
fiction or have a more technical focus
and are looking to reach policy makers
or the public
I asked key what kind of impact they
hoped their work would have on the world
I just want to hear a little bit about
what parts of your world do you hope
impact the broader world and how
I would love for the world to help bring
about a paradigm shift through a
conversation
so right now I think in the AI field the
conversation is how can we use AI how
can we make money from AI how can we
apply this amazing capabilities and in
the cultural world the conversation is
more like what does it mean who's going
to benefit is it sentient I would love
to combine those two conversations into
a question that's closer to how can we
meaningfully use AI to shift the
paradigms to solve the the challenges
that seem insoluble of climate and
inequality and political
factionalization
so I would love to see the addictions of
what it would really be like to graft AI
onto the human organism yeah and to
start to wonder about the effects and
the ethics of that I did recently watch
the movie after Yang
um have you heard of it no I have not
it's uh it's pretty good it's in this
world there's like the these technical
beings in human bodies called technos
and one family has bought one a Chinese
one to mentor to be an older brother for
their Chinese adopted daughter but at
one point in the film The the little
girl is talking about what does it mean
to be adopted and is she does she really
belong to her parents or her parents
really her parents and he takes her to
an apple orchard and he points to a
graft of one kind of apple tree onto
another kind of apple tree and he's like
look it's it's different but still
belongs to this apple tree but at the
same time it's also different and I
think this is one of the hardest things
for humans to hang on to which is this
sense of being different and related the
sense of being different and equal at
the same time and so I think that art
and and projects that help us
to be able to hold those two things
together is really powerful
yeah you explicitly mentioned in your
story like the humanities as an
important source of input as the world
progresses are there other kinds of
perspectives that that you'd really want
to see more of and stories about our
future I mean all the perspectives I
think we're we're we have too few I mean
in one sense we have too many
perspectives because the whole internet
is is like with voices and we can't we
can't organize or comprehend any of it
um and on the other hand it seems to be
the same kinds of narratives that are
surfaced again and again and I think in
particular when it comes to AI
um we the same apocalyptic scenarios are
raised again and again and that's I
think particularly potentially
problematic when it comes to the large
language models that are trained on yeah
existing discourse right like it can
become a self-fulfilling prophecies
where the stories that we tell about AI
are apocalyptic we train our our AI on
the apocalyptic narratives about
themselves the AI is faced with the
decision about what to do and it chooses
the most likely scenario as the
apocalyptic scenario
um so I think we have a real
responsibility to be more imaginative
um in terms of yeah like let's let's be
smart let's let's do our pre-mortem but
let's also have have the faith and the
courage to imagine different kinds of
stories and to tell them yeah
and are there any kinds of expertise
that you'd be most interested in having
kind of contribute to these
conversations
I mean part of me wants to say
yeah let's bring the philosophers on
board let's bring the the novel writers
and the artists and the activists those
people who haven't been a real part of
driving the direction that Ai and
technology is going and another part of
me thinks well maybe the question about
expertise is a little bit loaded or
Tilted in the wrong direction and and I
want to say what if we got together
sortation bodies yeah yeah you know what
if we do a panel of uh people from all
over the world and we educated them
about Ai and the risks and the
possibilities and the scenarios and we
had a truly Democratic Lottery based
conversation about where our priorities
are and what kinds of safeguards we want
to have and what what our goals are yeah
so after reading through your world and
in the comic and experiencing all of it
what do you hope that people stay
thinking about long after they've
encountered your stories
all right leaves us with the sense that
another world is possible that things
don't have to be the way that they are
that they could be a different and and
better way so I think I would more than
an answer or an idea I would want the
world to leave people with the question
how can AI meaningfully shift some of
the paradigms that we've taken for
granted
and to be open to the unknown be open to
the surprises and not just fall into the
pattern of oh I know what's going to
happen it's going to be the same rich
white guys who benefit from this and
it's going to be the same cycle all over
again no there might be you know a lot
of certainly a lot of factors
um tilt in that direction but what if it
wasn't what if it were something else
well this has been great thank you so
much for taking the time to chat about
your Creation with us
thank you so much for your wonderful
questions and really taking the time to
learn the world and engage with it it's
a lot of fun
[Music]
Our Guest today was key Rainer and Born
Free you can explore more of Key's work
at their website keybornfree.com that's
c-h-i bornfree.com
if you'd like to check out Micah's book
the end of protest a new playbook for
revolution or see the online school for
activists that he has co-founded you can
visit his website
micahmwhite.com that's
m-i-c-a-h-m-white.com
and for more of Jr's comics and
illustrations you can check out
jrcomicart.com
[Music]
if this podcast has got you thinking
about the future you can find out more
about this world and explore the ideas
contained in the other worlds at
www.worldbuild.ai
we want to hear your thoughts are these
worlds you'd want to live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast you
read all the comments and appreciate
every rating this podcast is produced
and edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute I is a
non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
touch with us or any of the teams
featured on the podcast to collaborate
you can email World build at
futureoflife.org
a reminder this podcast explores the
ideas created as part of fli's World
building contest and our hope is that
this series Sparks discussion about the
kinds of Futures we all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
[Music]